are your thoughts on very low dose, 3 milligrams of naltrexel before lying patients.
So low dose naltrexel or LDN is its even term. Now is an off-label use of a drug that was approved.
Years ago to help get people off addictions, it's a drug called naltrexel. It was typically approved
and I think 50 milligrams to get people off of addictive substances. But they found that low doses
of naltrexel act as an immune regulator. So it up regulates T-reg cells. So understand
your immune cells in your body. You have TH1, the gory, and TH is a couple of different ways
to classify an immune response. What is a TH1 versus a TH2 response?
TH1 is an immune response. It's an inflammatory response. It's how you kill pathogens.
A TH2 response is a secondary response. It's a cell mediated response. It's a B cell response.
It's how you make antibodies to take pathogens so that the TH1 response can fire again and kill
those pathogens. The problem is that with autoimmune diseases we can have this constant upregulation
of a TH1 response and you guys damaged to cell membranes, damaged to cells that you have antibodies.
So remember anytime you have antibodies to yourself, let's say you have antibodies to a thyroid gland.
So anytime you stimulate an immune response, anytime you have an uptick of that TH1 response.
And if you have a chronic uptick of that TH1 response, usually because you're not dealing with a
trigger, then you're going to be constantly killing your thyroid gland. You're going to be constantly
destroying that which you have antibodies against. Anytime you have an upregulation of your immune
system, whether you do it artificially because you are inadvertently and ignorantly taking immune
stimulants, they have an autoimmune disease that I keep taking vitamin C and garlic because my doctor
told me to take it because I have chronic Lyme. So I should be take cats, claw and garlic and vitamin C.
Well, what if you already have antibodies to self-tissue? Every time you're taking that substance,
you're stimulating immune response. And every time you stimulate immune response, you're going to kill
that which you have antibodies against. And if you have antibodies against your own body, you have
antibodies against self-tissue, aka you have an autoimmune disease that has been undiagnosed,
then you are going to cause more inflammation, more damage, more symptoms. And a lot of those people
go, oh my gosh, I have a Lyme flair. You don't really have a Lyme flair. You are causing damage to your
own cells. So stop taking those immune stimulants. Okay, maybe you're beyond that point and you've
educated yourself and now you're knowledgeable of that. Boy, I haven't taken immune stimulants for
a whole long time, but I keep getting these flares. My Lyme keeps flaring up. Well, you've got to look
for other triggers, like we talked about with other questions. You've got to dig in to find,
are there any foods that are triggers? Well, I'm already dairy free and gluten free, so what else
could it be? It could be a ton of other things. It could be anything else. You need to test for that.
There's other triggers too. Maybe it's the smell of gasoline, maybe it's the smell of mold,
maybe it's the smell of perfume, maybe it's things that, there's just a zillion things that could
be triggers. You're going to put on your Sherlock Holmes hat and figure this out because nobody can
completely, you can't test for all these things. You've got to try to figure out what are your triggers.
Now, there are some things that are what are called T-reg stimulators. So, whenever I say there's
a TH1 response and a TH2 response, and people that have constant autoimmune flares are stuck in a TH1
dominant situation, maybe by their own making, like I said. But there are some things, some nutritional
things, and some off-label medication that can stimulate T-reg cells. T-reg cells can help
calm down a TH1 response and calm down a TH2 response. They help balance that. So T-reg stimulators
can be good to take. Vitamin D is actually a T-reg stimulator. It's not an immune stimulator.
And what this person asked, LDN, low dose-deltrexone, has been found to be a T-reg stimulator.
So, that's why it's been found to be helpful for autoimmune conditions because it helps calm down
that TH1 response. So, yes, so it could be helpful. Typically, people start by taking 1.5 milligrams,
go up to 3 milligrams, and then go up to 4.5 milligrams. And that's considered,
as other persons wait to. But that's considered low dose-deltrexone, and it could be very
beneficial for autoimmune patients.